well obviously I don't know anything
about card tricks or magic tricks but I
do know a lot about being an
entrepreneur and business playing intro
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome to my brand new
channel for those of you don't know me
or masters of architecture graduate and
over the past few years I've used those
skills to dive headfirst into the econ
game I've managed to grow multiple
businesses from the ground up
nothing too internationally recognized
in under three years and I'm assuming
because you're watching this video
chances are you want to do something
similar to don't know where to start
look I'm no guru nor am I going to try
so you might masterclass that's just BS
in my opinion but what I'm gonna do on
this channel is teach you all the tips
tricks and skills that I've learned over
the past few years and potentially help
you start your very own business in 2019
we're gonna be covering lots of topics
here from camera gear to lenses to
Photoshop and all the Adobe programs but
we're also gonna be covering how health
and fitness can help you accomplish more
in your day but before we do that let's
take a quick office to a because you're
gonna be seeing a lot more of this a lot
more often
[Music]
how come you think that a stick
three more than the pouring rain
[Music]
I hope you like that little edit but
let's dive right on into what we're
gonna be covering over the next few
weeks so the basic plan is to launch two
to four videos every week 50% of those
videos are going to be econ tutorials
whilst the other 50% are going to be
Fitness related voiceovers in the econ
tutorials we're going to be covering a
lot of software and a lot of camera gear
basically everything that you need to
start and launch a first product the
other ones tube videos are going to be
Fitness based tutorials now you're
probably thinking why on earth am i
doing fitness and EECOM at the same time
well I don't know about you guys but
when I'm hungry I can't focus when I'm
tired I can't work efficiently and worst
of all when I'm not eating properly
I get very lethargic now when I train in
the morning and I eat properly my mind's
awake my body's ready
I personally believe in taking the time
to focus on your mental and physical
health in order to be able to perform at
the highest level the longest period of
time this is a journey I've been
thinking about studying for a while now
and I'm hoping that you're gonna join me
along the way
smash that subscribe button and I'll see
you in the next one